hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting games between two leaders to
current leaders of the Kashima memorial
2018 Magnus Carlsen and the Veselin
Topalov well Veselin Topalov is the
actual leader but Carson is definitely
trying to catch up and when it's a clash
of two leaders it's always nice to have
the white pieces the game really starts
off in a quiet tone and I'm not just
saying that because it's a like a
peaceful boring game it's because the
line costs and chooses is actually
called the quiet line but you'll see
what I mean by this but before we
actually see the game I do have a couple
of photos for you to enjoy here we have
this is a photo from their game I
decided to blur the position and there
was also a little board we were crossing
it so I had to blur that as well but
that's them at about in the middle of
the game I don't want to spoil it with
the position here we also have their
all-time record between Magnus Carlsen
Veselin Topalov
so cos and beat the paul of 8 to 5 with
11 rows that's in classical time format
so not not that great of a result in
Carlson's favor as one would expect but
if you check if you check rapid slash
exhibition games then you can see that
constant score against Apollo is 15 to 1
with a draws so Topalov although to
Paulo always said that he would enjoy
that chess isn't played in such a long
time time format that a lot of the games
would be more interesting as you can see
here considering his score against calls
Carlsen he definitely prefers the slower
time format then we have a wild photo
here this is a photo also from around 7
it's rough Mammadov in the middle and
there you can see his birthday cake
today is Ralph's mama dog's birthday and
he had a very nice game against Geary
today a couple of years ago he played
against cost and on his birthday but
cousin beat him unfortunately he
couldn't win that game and today he
couldn't win a game against Geary either
he but he drew the game so it's not such
a bad birthday present and there you can
see on the right Lou boomer Lubavitch
the legendary Grandmaster
and a lot of a lot of people on the left
from Azerbaijan who decided to
congratulate off Mamedov and also I did
prepare one other photo as it was a rest
day yesterday so here are the here is
the winning team I don't have I don't
really know who the guy in the suit is
but then there you have Peter Nelson hi
and cousins coach and there's Magnus
Carson holding the trophy there's Dean
liver and then two guys I don't really
know who they are and then Veselin to
follow all the way on the right and it's
interesting that a lot of you probably
saw cars and playing soccer now and then
but it's actually ding gluon who handles
the ball really well there's not a
there's not like a video of the entire
soccer match but I did catch a glimpse
of it they thrown they've thrown a
couple of video shots and you know you
should really see the England how he
handles the ball if he didn't become
such a great chess player I'm sure I'm
sure he would have been a great soccer
player it's interesting why he chose
chess you know but yeah let's see this
game so Carson has the white pieces and
he opens with c4 we have 90 to a6 Knight
to c3 so the English opening is on the
board
'if I've the two knights variation
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and here
Carlson has a couple of options he can
go efore he can go d4 he can go a three
this is the court you know a variation
that immediately prevents black from
going Bishop to b4 but cross and chooses
III this is something called the quiet
line of the four Knights of the English
Bishop to b4 by by top all of Queen to
c2 and now Bishop captures on c3 now you
can see the bishop can be captured by
the b-pawn by the D pawn and also by the
Queen so you know there are a lot of
principles here maybe you know you want
to capture with the Queen you don't want
to ruin your phone structure then you
have do you want to capture with this
point or with this point you don't want
to capture away from the center you want
to capture towards the center but B
captors and c3 is definitely the better
move as it can it kind of prevents this
Knight from going anywhere it locks down
before it gives more control of the d4
square so definitely a better move and
the Queen will be useful on c2
we'll give protection to the 2d
Foursquare 1.1 the point is pushed d6 we
have e4 now castles and the g3 and here
it's it's not an everyday position of
this variation top olive can definitely
go for something like a brush up to g4
and after Bishop to g2 Queen to d7 a
with ideas of playing Bishop to h3 and
after call sand castles he can then
decide if he wants to play Bishop - tree
immediately or develop in some other
fashion but as the pollo is the leader
in this tournament he decides to play
like a true leader and he plays in
Knights to e8 he wants to go immediately
at 5 and you know start start releasing
the tension from the position
Knight to h4 Carlsen prevents f5 we have
Knight to e7 now again planning f5 we
have d3 and now finally to Paul of does
display f5 e captures an f5 Knight
captures an f5 Knight captures Bishop
captures and Bishop to g2 a developing
the bishop preparing to castle also
eyeing the b7 pawn c6 the pole prevents
this and now h3 h3 is a very useful move
it prevents the knight from infiltrating
via the g4 square also after the power
does decide to play Queen to d7 and
Carson castles this will make a nice
sanctuary for the King on h2 then the
King and the bishop will both be
guarding the h3 pawns so a lot of a lot
of useful things this h3 pawn does so
nice the c7 and not the pallav has a
different idea he sees that the d3 point
is currently weak and not only its weak
it's also pinned as the queen is on c2
so to polish plan is to play 96-95 and
from c5 denied will also pressure the D
pawn so we have castles by Carlson now
comes 296 preparing Knight c5 and the
Bishop to e3
now night c5 can always be met with
Bishop captures on c5 Knight c5
nevertheless and first Carlsen plays
rook to d1 located e1 he doesn't want to
capture immediately as he still does
have the bishop pair he wants to he
wants to hang on to it as long as
possible Queen to d7 attacking the h3
pawn and now key
- H - the move we discussed brush up to
g6 and rook to d2 across and is
preparing to double rooks on the D file
as he knows the d3 pawn will come will
you know get under siege rook 88 and now
Queen to d1 we have b6 and rook to e1 h
6 by top all of Bishop captures on c5
pawn captures on c5 and now rook to e3
Carson makes a nice rook lift and the
rook from e3 will once again be
defending the d3 pawn rook to e6 we have
King - g1 and now rook to d6 preparing
to bring the other rock all the way to
d8
you know exert even more pressure to the
d3 pointless now the Queen the rook and
the bishop are attacking it when the row
comes to d8 and then there will be four
pieces as I can get
we have h4 by Carlsen improving the
position there is still no threat and of
course you don't want to capture on e5
if you kept 25 then the d3 point will
fall so first colors and improves the
position and now it's an interesting
moment the pollo should definitely play
rook to e8 simply protecting this pawn
but here to Pollock lay the rope to the
8th and the very interesting turn of
events takes place here rook captures on
e5 cross and seize upon and he grabs it
we have a bit of capture Sun d3 the ball
of captures back the pawn and now comes
a bishop to e4 it's hard to say that is
this the move to Paul of missed by
Carson because now this bishop is under
attack and there are a whole lot of
tactics involved the the rook to e8 move
and maybe this is the move the power
missed maybe rook to e8 will be
something to Paulo missed and here if
you go Bishop captures on e4 then you
get rook captures on d6 Queen captures
and now this rook to e8 check
unfortunately if you move the king then
rook captures rook and it's game over
for black so here you have captured rook
and Queen captures Queen and d6 it's a
queen against the rook and the bishop
but with a much better position for
white which is similar to what
happen in the game it's interesting
after this Bishop to b4 move black does
have black does have a way of playing
this he has to play pink to f8 and this
leads to a pretty forced variation which
is hard to say if the poll of saudis
after queen to f3 check King back to g8
not comes the Bishop captures in c6
Queen captures Queen captures rook
captures and now it seems like black is
up a piece but not really because the
White has this rook to d5 move attacking
the rook and also there's a double
attack on the bishop now if you move the
bishop then the two rooks will capture I
mean a route will capture on da so here
you have the capture capture and now the
bishop is under attack but also the rook
and have to rope to d6 now you capture
and after all this is 7 done it's six
points the five for white white is of
course preparing c4 softer b5 white is
still up a pawn but it's hard to say if
white can actually win this so this
would definitely beat Apollo the best
bet but after Bishop to b4 top olive
actually played Bishop captures on c4
which kind of tells us that he did miss
cousins rook e8 idea here cousin simply
played rook captures and e6 Queen
captures and now rook to e8 check and of
course if you move the King doesn't
matter where
then simply wrote captors and e8 and
it's game over if Queen captures and e1
rook will capture the Queen if Queen
captures rook Queen capture screen
that's even worse so rook captures on
the 8th and Queen captures on d6 and
rook captures any force so once again
it's Queen against the bishop and the
rook but you know it's it's not it's not
all that easy to play this here
Queen captures on c6 grabbing the pawn
also this comes with an attack on the
rook rook to e1 check King to h2 and now
Bishop captures on a2 and here it's an
interesting position cousin can start
play with ideas like Queen a8
check and after king will start picking
up those pawns but after the Queen
captures an a7 then he doesn't want to
allow ideas like Bishop to d5 eyeing h2
and then ideas like rook to h1 so first
to prevent any tricks like this he's
playing against the ball - pollo is an
excellent technician firstly plays g4 so
no no
more ideas like this or ever possible
King to h7 getting his King to safety
not allowing any any tricks by Carson to
pick up one of the pieces we have f4 we
have h five and now f5 h captors on g4
and h6 h5 now going to g6 with check is
coming and then after the King moves h6
and f6 will be very powerful
so Bishop to f7 not allowing Queen to g6
we have Queen to b7 now attacking the
bishop and the a7 pawn you have to now
start picking up those pawns King g8 we
have Queen captures on a7 Bishop
captures on h5 and now Queen captures on
b6 c4 but now comes Queen to d8 check
Bishop to d8 and King to g3 after King
to g3 this is Carson's move 41 so time
control has been reached and Topalov now
goes into a deep think not not too big
of I think some 20 minute 20 minute long
thing and if you ask the engine here the
engine will say white is much better not
white is winning you every will just say
what is much better and it offers came
to fa king to f8 what idea is that the
king will not protect the bishop and
that the rook can now move but the pulse
played King to h7 and now the engines
evaluation turns immediately into white
is winning and from here on cousin did
play pretty fast so Carson seems to know
this 20 c7 now the threat is f6 of
course as the G pawn is pinned and here
you can play a rook to f1 protect a
guard against f6 this way but then
simply King captures and white will
slowly but surely make progress after
Queen to c7 top olive tried King to g8
but now comes Queen captures on c4 with
chick Bishop to f7
and now of course your queen is under
attack and you don't want to play a move
like Queen captures on g4 if you do this
rope to g1 you lose the game
so after Bishop to have 7 Queen to d4 we
have rook to e8 the ball has to try and
activate his pieces somehow and now
comes c4 now cause
starts pushing his past c-pawn and
there's not much to Paulo can do here
rook to f8 preparing to move the bishop
c5 and now Bishop to eh and here to Paul
of kinda sets a trap but you'll see
you'll see it's not it's not all that
easy cross implies Queen to d5 check we
have King to h7 and now here is a great
position for you to analyze what's
causing the best idea here and what
would you play in this position how many
of you would push c6
that's the real question well if you
played c6 you would still be winning but
the question is would you know that you
will be winning because this was
actually an attempt of a trick by
Topalov if Carson played c6 here then
two polyps the idea was Bishop captures
on c6 Queen captures and rook captures
and on f5 and now after King chapters in
g4 rope to f6 and now this here this
here structure is actually a fortress
there is no way for white to win this
game whatever you try queenie for king
goes back this rook is covering the
entire 6th rank and the rook is defended
by the pawn there is no way for the
White King to ever approach anywhere
near because there is no way for the
White King to pass the 6th rank and
there's nothing the Queen can do alone
so this was an attempt at an attempt by
the pallav to to create this kind of a
fortress
unfortunately for topalov it wouldn't
work because after this King captors in
g4 after this King captors on g4 this
wouldn't be played immediately instead
of capturing on g4 Queen to e4 and now
white is winning the palm is this but
you know he had to give it give it a
shot because now you either play g6 and
there is no more fortress or you have to
come in with the king and 19 captures on
g4 wins the rook and the game but Carson
doesn't want to allow any of this nor
maybe he's just lazy as Geary to
calculate he plays Queen to e6 and now
Carlsen sets a trap
for the power we have Bishop to b5 now
again the pouf is kind of waiting for
Carson to push c6 and interestingly here
c6 is played but now it's a difference
we have Bishop captures but now we have
Queen to g6 first not capturing the
bishop if you capture the bishop you
enter the same line which which would
still be winning for Carlsen but there
is that idea of fortress and well either
Carson didn't see the win or he was just
lazy to calculate it because he found
another win after this after this Bishop
captures on c6 Queen to g6 comes with
check now comes King to g8 and now Queen
captures on c6 here of course knock now
things become apparent
you can't capture on f5 because now
Queen to c8 the king is on the last rank
this picks up the rook you lose the game
so after Queen captures on c6 the polo
tried rope to f6 but now comes Queen to
e8 check King to h7 and now King
captures on g4 finally and it's
interesting because there is a pawn on
f5 this is no longer a fortress and the
cousin is here to prove it we have
looked to h6 to Paulo simply top Allah's
plan is simply to play rook h6 back to
f6 then back to h6 and this this is the
Paulo's idea now and it's interesting
how to win this you're welcome to try
and pause the video here and try to find
a winning idea for white so for those of
you who found it congratulations you are
an excellent and game player and you
also don't believe in fortresses and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
here King to f4 was played with the
following idea the ball plays rook to f6
we have King to e5 the Polo plays rook
back to h6 and here we have Queen to e6
and it was in this position that's the
pole finally resigned the game why did
you resign well there is really nothing
more for you to do here if you capture
the Queen then you get the pawn captures
and there is no way to stop this pond
from queening and other than capturing
you really don't have any any options
here so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it an excellent game by
Carlsen but you know not so much not so
much an excellent game by cousin but
it's very interesting why this topple of
Miss that rook to e8 move
or did he even miss it maybe he wanted
to go into this but that's kind of hard
to believe because white wasn't so so
much better here but he was definitely
better so it's very interesting so yeah
I do have a one other thing I prepared
for you after this Queen to e6 move they
shook hands this is a photo of that
moment so there you have it
Queen to e6 on the board to Paulo
resigns and I win for Carlsen I don't
have the standings after this round
because some of the games are still
being played but it's I think it's
definite now that Carlsen after
defeating tupolev takes a sole lead in
this tournament so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting game
probably from the US Chess Championship
thank you
[Music]